welcome back to the program earlier I
mentioned that there were two very
famous quite pregnant actresses here
tonight
I actually was incorrect I've become
aware that there is a third so here's
what we've got so far
Jessica Alba he's pregnant Cate
Blanchett he's pregnant and Nicole
Kidman is pregnant as well so this is so
exciting the baby goes to
oh my god this is Angelina Jolie I'm
just done
obviously Angelina couldn't be with us
tonight stuff to get 17 babysitter's on
Oscar night so uh I'll accept this baby
on her behalf please welcome to the
stage Academy Award winners Dame Judi
Dench and Halle Berry
by now you figured out that Ally and
Dame Judi couldn't be here tonight so
they grabbed us from the audience to
fill in and since they didn't have time
to write something new for us we're
gonna use the script they wrote for them
your game Judi you go first
wait wait why am i Dame Judi Wyatt why
aren't i Halle Berry are you kidding me
dude obviously I'm Halle Berry I look
more like her we look exactly the same
dude are you why why are you more Halle
Berry than I am because I just give off
like a Halle Berry vibe I mean why wait
wait so I give off a Judi Dench vibe
ezeli you're not so much you give off a
dame judi vibe it's just you give up a
not Halle Berry vibe
what's all it means and you did there's
nothing she's crazy I love her I just
always saw myself as more of a Halle
Berry type personally I don't know being
a baby I don't the nominees for best
sound editing are
Karen Baker Landers and hare Halbert for
the Bourne Ultimatum skip let's say for
No Country for Old Men
Randy Tom and Michael silvers for
ratatouille Christopher Scarah Bozzio
and Matthew wood for there will be blood
Ethan van der run and Mike Hopkins for
transformers and the Oscar goes to Karen
Baker Landers and / Hamburg for The
Bourne Ultimatum
oh my god I went blank
um it it's such an honor to be here I
want to thank we want to thank the
Academy we want to thank Universal
Studios and the pleasure of doing
something like this with filmmakers like
Paul I'm blanking out to Frank Marshall
Pat Crowley Crowley Chris rouse
krisstraus Paul Greengrass mixers Scott
Juan David Parker we planned this and we
blew it
yeah anyway most of all we want to thank
of course our crew that works with us
every day
yes gosh Chrissa cells dan Hegeman you
know I know music thank you so much
just go just go
good evening I'm miss Halle Berry and
I'm Dame Judi Dench I know you're
thinking how can you be Dame Judi Dench
you clearly look way more like Halle
Berry and I the real Halle Berry also
know what you're thinking and you're
correct
thank you I am glowing I'm Halle Berry
the nominees for best sound mixing are
Scott Mullin David Parker and Kurt
Francis for the Bourne Ultimatum skip
lev say craig Berkey greg Orloff and
peter Curlin for No Country for Old Men
Randy Tom Michael semanek and dot King
for R attitude
Paul Massey David Jia Marco and Jim
stouby for 3:10 to Yuma Kevin O'Connell
Greg P Russell and Peter J Devlin for
transformers and the winner is sorry
these Halle Berry hands get to me Scott
Milan David Parker and Kirk Francis for
the Bourne Ultimatum
would it be all right to kiss Halle
Berry now we'd like to thank the Academy
certainly and hair and Karen just think
principally everybody Frank Marshall and
that crowd
our director Paul Greengrass Chris
Morales our picture editor everybody
Universal parent care and of course
everybody toddy o our team there and I'd
like to add one thing in a kind of a
somber note this last week we lost a
colleague and a friend was also a member
of the Board of Governors here at the
Academy name was Paul Huntsman and I'd
like to dedicate this to Paul so thank
you very much
the award for the best actress last
year's award winner bill Holden Grace
Kelly for the country girl rely on
woodworking three faces of Eve
Elizabeth Palin gotta compete Julie
Andrews is famous for your hospitality
but this is really ridiculous interested
in God Jane Fonda a clue Liza Minnelli
my fault you are seeing my dream come
true
Faye Dunaway Sally Field has named the
Ray [ __ ] Spacek he coalminers daughter
marvelous Meryl Streep
this means that I am somebody but I
guess I'm on my way
Jodie Foster Jessica Tandy's and Driving
Miss Daisy I'm on cloud nine Kathy Bates
I would like to thank my dad who I hope
is watching somewhere Emma Thompson
Holly Hunter Jessica Lange Susan
Sarandon Rodgers McDorman Paul TRO Julia
Robert Halle Berry
Nicole Kidman Charlize Tyrese
Witherspoon and the Oscar goes to Helen
Mirren in the Queen ladies and gentlemen
I give you the Queen
and now to present this year's award for
lead actress Academy Award winner Forest
Whitaker
Marlon Brando's said that to grasp the
full significance of life is the actors
duty to interpret it is his problem and
to express it
his dedication he could have added them
when a superbly talented woman can
inhabit a character and make it her own
it's acting at its best these five
performances all of which are like that
the nominees for actress and a leading
role are Cate Blanchet in Elizabeth the
Golden Age Julie Christie and away from
her
Marion Cotillard I love young roots
Lauren link in the savages
Ellen Page Anjuna